we've learned that a moderate level of
inflation is normally associated with
the good economy but what we saw and we
in particular we saw in the early 70s in
1973 when the oil embargo hit is that we
started to experience something called
stagflation or there's something that
was kind of labeled stagflation it's
this weird bizarre circumstance where
you have inflation at the same time as
stagnation in the economy so that's
where they get this kind of combination
of words of stagflation let's think
about how that would happen in
particular let's think about how that
would happen due to a supply shock
there's other ways that you could get
stagflation if if you have strange
regulations over-regulation if the
government does weird things but the
classic example is a supply shock and we
say supply shock it's something like an
oil embargo where all of a sudden the
supply of oil the supply of something
just goes down goes down dramatically
and it could become because of some type
of emergency or it could be literally
because of an embargo and just think
about what the what how that would
affect the rest of this chain so the
supply of something dramatically goes
down we know that supply has an inverse
relationship with price so supply goes
down then BAM right there you see price
price would immediately go up and we
think about something like oil you might
say anyway that just you know oil is
only the part of my pocketbook where I
drive around but it's not because even
when you buy a fruit you're really
paying for the transportation cost so
the price of oil affects fruit affects
food affects any good in services it's
one of these things that's pervasive
through the economy so the prices of a
bunch of things could generally go up
well if the price of a bunch of things
generally go up what's going to happen
to demand once again inverse
relationship right over here demand
demand is going to plummet demands going
to plummet if demand plummets
utilization plummets utilization
plummets investment plummets and profit
is going to plummet and profits going to
plummet now because one utilization is
going down and price has gone up but
it's not the price that they can sell
things at now price is fundamentally a
big cost for especially if you think of
if you think of a from a us-centric
point of view if oil is an import
in the case of the early 70s then prices
also prices also price going up is going
to have in or I guess they have an
inverse relationship so the price goes
up is really going to be on the cost
side so once again hitting profits hard
and if all of these things go down
that's just going to kill employment
kill wages and then further make demand
even worse so stagflation is that
situation where you have some type of
shock to the system where in in the kind
of a classic scenario it hits supply so
hard it causes a massive inflation in
one part of the economy and in the case
of oil part that affects other parts of
the economy and then all of that kind of
throws a monkey wrench in everything
else